bonjour est ravie de vous retrouver à
bruxelles au parlement européen pour
cette nouvelle saison de roberto
dans cette émission direction la grèce
où la crise économique est en train de
virer à la crise sanitaire les grecs
n'ont plus les moyens de se soigner les
hôpitaux n'ont plus de médicaments nous
serons avec médecins du monde qui vient
d'ouvrir là bas un dispensaire
l'actualité c'est aussi le pacte
budgétaire européen qui suscite la
cacophonie en france mais peut-on
vraiment s'en passer c'est la question
de la semaine 2 mars 2012 sommet de
bruxelles 25 pays s'engagent à réduire
leur dette et ramener leurs comptes à
l'équilibré
parmi les signataires du traité
l'allemagne d'angela merkel et la france
de nicolas sarkozy
deux pays refusent le pacte la
grande-bretagne et la république tchèque
deux mois plus tard un pacte de
croissance est adopté à la demande du
nouveau président français comparé à
d'autres traités le texte est très court
24 pages ses articles et surtout une
fameuse règle d'or le déficit public
structurel ne doit pas dépasser 0,5 pour
cent de la richesse d'un pays autre
interdiction la dette des pays
signataires doit être inférieur à 60% du
produit intérieur brut
et attention ceux qui violent les règles
seront passibles de sanctions infligées
par la cour européenne de justice
des pénalités pouvant atteindre 0,1 pour
cent du pib soit quelque deux milliards
d'euros pour la france
le traité est en cours de ratification
dans une dizaine de pays dont
l'allemagne la belgique les pays bas et
la france où le texte sera présenté à
l'assemblée le 2 octobre si tout le
monde accepte la nécessité de réduire la
dette certains économistes estiment que
ce traité adopté en période de crise
condamne les états à la rigueur une
potion amère mais peut-on vraiment se
passer du traité budgétaire
pour cette première émission de la
saison philippe lambert c'est avec nous
bonjour vous êtes député coprésident du
parti des verts et puis spécialistes ici
des questions économiques au parlement
européen or ce traité budgétaire est
critiquée en france il suscite même une
véritable cacophonie chez les verts des
instances du parti chez nous ont rejeté
ce traité est ce que vous vous comprenez
cette cacophonie
je ne sais pas si on peut parler de
cacophonie quand vous avez une décision
qui est prise par 70% d'une assemblée je
pense que c'est un vote très net est
donc là je pense que la cacophonie est
causée par certains déçus du vote des
verts je peux comprendre qu'ils soient
déçus mais il faut aussi respecter la
loi de la majorité la question vous
posiez c'est peut-on se passer de ce
traité la réponse est oui absolument
que fait ce traité ils répètent des
choses qui se trouve déjà dans le droit
européen et on peut se demander mais
pourquoi et bien parce que certains en
europe et en amérique et de la première
n'ont pas confiance dans le droit
européen et dans la capacité de la
commission de faire respecter ce droit
par des états membres la seule
différence qu'il ya entre ce qui est
inscrit aujourd'hui vous savez c'est
tout le débat sur le six pack la
gouvernance économique européenne
ce qu'il y a dans le droit européen et
ce traité c'est un resserrement de la
norme de déficit structurel a créé table
1 point de pib à 0,5 point p qu'est ce
que ça change pour ben ça veut dire que
simplement on veut encore encadré plus
fort
non pas les déficits publics mais bien
les dépenses publiques car le problème
de ce traité c'est qu'il est
déséquilibré c'est à dire que au lieu
il annonce qu'il veut réduire les
déficits mais en réalité le seul moyen
d'action qu'on les états membres
c'est couper dans les dépenses pourquoi
parce que sur le front des recettes des
impôts la loi qui joue n'est pas celle
de la coopération et de la discipline
commune c'est la loi de la compétition
débridée entre les états membres
et vous savez que la compétition fiscale
mène les recettes à descendre toujours
plus aujourd'hui des plats plupart des
multinationales européennes payent 2 ou
3 % d'impôt sur leurs bénéfices ce qui
est évidemment incompatible avec les
profits qu'elles font et ce qui veut
dire que donc on affaiblit les recettes
des états membres et on leur demande
d'équilibrer leur budget en périodes en
plus de ça où la crise s'approfondit et
donc où toutes les dépenses de sécurité
sociale par exemple augmentent
on voit bien ce à quoi ça mène pour vous
résumer en quelques mots
vous dites que ce traité c'est une
menace pour la croissance
en tout cas c'est une menace pour le bon
fonctionnement de l'économie européenne
si on veut avoir une stratégie crédible
de remise en route et de réorientation
de l'économie européenne
mais c'est clair que ce traité est un
symbole très largement mais qui se
trouve en travers de ses troupes alors à
la demande du nouveau président français
élu en mai dernier françois hollande un
pacte de croissance a été adoptée à côté
de ce traité budgétaire est ce qu'il est
suffisant pour ça va évidemment
absolument rien à voir si je peux me
permettre de faire une comparaison c'est
comme si vous vous engagez à faire un
régime pour les 30 ou 40 ou 50 ans on ne
sait pas au fait puisque c'est illimité
dans le temps qui viennent
mais en contrepartie on vous permet
d'aller une fois au restaurant manger un
steak frites avant de commencer votre
régime à quoi est-ce que ça arrive je
veux dire on ne peut pas mettre sur le
même pied à traiter permanents et des
investissements ponctuels qui porte sur
tenez vous bien 0,5 pour cent du pib
européen autrement dit on va s'engager à
investir si tout va bien si tout va bien
un demi point de pib en 2012 2013 2014
en échange d'une discipline budgétaire
qui est excessive pour les 30 40 50 ans
qui viennent ça n'a évidemment on ne
peut pas mettre les deux choses en
rapport
c'est à dire que les états vont pieds et
mains liés perdront des marges de
manoeuvre et ben vous ça va pas réglé
pour autant les problèmes non non
maintenant le principe d'une monnaie
partager le fait qu'une monnaie partager
exige une discipline commune
aucune discussion là dessus mais tout
mais tout dispositif est en place dans
le cadre du droit européen ce traité
c'est une sucette que l'on donne à
angela merkel pour quelque part apaiser
l'opinion publique allemande
tout le monde et ça donne du mois
décembre quand on négocier ce pacte et
que j'en discutais avec le président la
commission comme disait-il
et bien quand ils défient dans mon
bureau les 26 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement me dit ce traité on n'en
veut pas ça ne sert à rien tout et des
friandises politique finalement au fond
c'est complètement c'est d'un symbole
que l'on veut donner pour apc
la chancelière allemande et le peuple
allemand désole le peuple allemand est
aussi
motivés par des parts des motivations où
l'irrationnel à sa part qui est dû à
l'histoire allemande mais je rassure
l'allemagne eux il y a également des
préoccupations qui ne sont pas de même
nature dans d'autres états européens et
on peut pas faire l'europe simplement en
exécutant la volonté fut-elle fut-elle
acceptable du peuple allemand désolé les
allemands pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
respect sont 80 millions de citoyens
européens ils ne sont pas les 500
millions et donc on ne peut pas faire à
traiter exclusivement pour complaire à
une chancelière qui en réalité a du mal
à tenir tête à son opinion publique
donc pour vous il manque un certain
contrôle démocratique où c'est cette
évidence est évident aujourd'hui et ça
c'est celle là c'est rio a adopté ces
passionnantes et a dû traiter dans toute
la gouvernance économique européenne
on se trouve dans une situation
aujourd'hui où une commission européenne
prend des décisions de nature politique
en grèce au portugal etc
alors on peut dire elle est négocié avec
des gouvernements et du oui mais en
réalité tout le monde sait bien qu'elle
impose un certain nombre de choix sans
savoir comme le dit paul de gros qui est
un libéral prof d'économie mais donc
ancien sénateur libéral en belgique il
dit la commission prend des décisions
dont elle n'a pas à payer le prix
politique ça ne va pas on ne peut pas
confier des décisions politiques à une
instance qui n'est pas comptable de ses
actes démocratiquement et ça c'est ce
qu'on doit mettre en place si on veut
vraiment faire accepter la gouvernance
économique européenne par des peuples
alors daniel cohn bendit dj une chose un
peu différente une proposition vous
l'assumez il dit aussi qu'ils que c'est
quand même un moyen de régler cette
crise qui n'en faisaient le havrais
s'est tout simplement factuellement faux
aujourd'hui tout le dispositif que nous
avons mis en place au niveau de la
gouvernance économique européenne
clairement le droit européen permet de
faire tout ce que l'on veut en terme de
discipline budgétaire et et je vous dis
ce traité est purement symbolique mais à
dix ans d'un maillot avec des sanctions
positionné pour évidemment non mais
finalement les règles et je préfère
quand même que des sanctions soient
prises par une commission que par une
cour de justice européenne enfin on ne
peut quand même pas le gouvernement des
juges ce serait encore un
affaiblissement sarre union européenne
ceux-ci ceci étant c'est clair que le
seul point sur lequel la cour de justice
peut vraiment attaquer les états c'est
sur la non traduction dans leur droit
national
de la règle d'or est donc elle ne peut
pas se mettre à l qui va surveiller
l'exécution de la règle d'or c'est
simplement la transposition dans le
droit national qui est soumise à
l'arrimer comme comme dans tous le droit
européen de la cour européenne de
justice mais de toute manière il y a
aujourd'hui tout un dispositif avec les
sanctions à la clé pour assurer la
discipline budgétaire dans l'union
pourquoi peloton se traiter en plus
alors on a bien compris notre message va
passer à un autre sujet au menu de
l'actualité européenne les ogm puisqu'un
film une étude scientifique choc
viennent de sortir et font beaucoup vous
font couler beaucoup d'encre en france
regardez ce zapping et ses images
impressionnantes on en parle juste après
cette image a fait le tour du monde
un rat de laboratoire nourris aux ogm du
géant américain monsanto la tumeur
mammaire que cette femelle à développer
fait froid dans le dos pendant deux ans
des chercheurs français ont travaillé
dans le plus grand secret sur des rats
nourris au maïs transgénique traiter ou
non à l'herbicide roundup monsanto
l'entreprise qui développe ses maïs
explique qu'elle prendra en compte ces
résultats mais selon des centaines
d'autres études scientifiques
ce maïs est sans danger et la
méthodologie de l'étude en question est
critiqué
quels produits peuvent contenir des ogm
dans les rayons supermarché le lait la
viande et les oeufs sont les plus
concernés ils le sont indirectement
quand les bêtes sont nourries par des
céréales ogm importés et dans ce cas là
il n'y a aucune obligation de l'indiquer
et voilà le former sur ja qu'on l'achète
là on achète sa baisse inquiet devant
que c'est pas trop trop d'où on ne sait
pas trop d'où en fait le soja est
composée deuxième à 95%
il provient essentiellement d'argentine
du brésil cela fait des années que cet
éleveur de vaches laitières nourrit son
cheptel avec une question d'efficacité
c'est un problème contre le génie
génétique on peut faire de l'insuline
avec du génie génétique
c'est un problème de prendre des champs
des agriculteurs pour une paillasse de
scientifiques et les assiettes de
consommateurs pour une période
industrielle et ça on peut pas accepter
si on ne fait pas de test voilà alors
cette étude en question et a été réalisé
par gilles eric séralini un scientifique
qui est connu pour être ses positions
contre les ogm elle a été publiée dans
une revue scientifique est ce que pour
vous il faut la prendre ce qu'il faut
prendre cette étude au sérieux mais
qu'il ya urgence à agir
ce n'est pas moi qui dit qu'il faut la
prendre au sérieux ce sont tous les
scientifiques qui ont vérifié ce papier
avant qu'ils soient publiés dans une
revue scientifique
il ya tout un processus de contrôle de
la validité des résultats on n'aurait
pas pu publier cette étude si des
scientifiques n'avaient pas dit ça nous
semble sérieux donc s'il me le dise je
ne suis qu'un ingénieur je ne suis pas
scientifique et donc j'imagine que ça
doit être pris au sérieux mais d'autres
scientifiques disent non cette étude est
partial
seuls des petits échantillons ont été
testés
c'est un peu comme chercher des poux de
rethel et j'aimerais bien alors qu'il
trouvait j'aimerais bien que les mêmes
scientifiques disent ce qu'ils pensent
des études faites par monsanto et
d'autres qui porte sur des échantillons
encore plus faibles sur des durées
encore plus faibles et où les effets
combinés de l'eau gm et de la glycine ne
sont pas
ne sont pas mesurés donc je dis si cette
étude a des carences scientifiques et
bien que nous les vérifions et que nous
les redressions si ici s'il y en a mais
je pense que si cette attitude est
considérée comme ayant des 40
scientifiques
je pense que les études réalisées par
l'industrie des ogm sont encore plus
suspecte d'autant plus qu'à aller
franchement lorsque vous étiez
étudiantes et étudiants bien sûr on
aurait bien aimé s'évaluer nous mêmes
mais quelle est la crédibilité d'études
réalisées par ceux qui ont un intérêt à
ce que ces études donnent des résultats
positifs je le dire en général on ne
demande pas aux étudiants de sévaz
lui-même ne demande pas aux industriels
d'évaluer eux mêmes les produits qu'ils
mettent sur le marché
or c'est le cas aujourd'hui alors en
attendant les ogm la culture des ogm est
interdite en france en italie puisqu'il
ya eu un moratoire mais c'est pas pour
autant qu'elle se retrouve pas dans la
même veine à menton et finalement des
nourritures alliés animal il ya des
craintes aujourd'hui le citoyen européen
mange peut-être des ogm sans savoir non
pas peut-être nous mangeons tous ces ogm
et donc nous le savons la question c'est
pouvons nous sortir de cette de cette de
cette impasse autrement dit aujourd'hui
au lieu de laisser jouer la logique du
marché qui permettrait aux consommateurs
de choisir de dire par exemple eh bien
je souhaite acheter des produits sans
ogm
aujourd'hui l'industrie se bat pour que
par exemple nous n'effectuons pas les
produits nooooon
exo gm de manière visible et ne veut pas
la transparence et ne veut pas la
transparence des études scientifiques de
cette propres études scientifiques
elle ne veut pas la transparence de
l'équité j'ai donc je me pose la
question
qu'at-elle à cacher est-elle à ce point
un créatif du marché la réaction des
clients pour que l neveu et les feuilles
les s'entretenir dans le doute est donc
aujourd'hui je suis désolé de le dire
mais les obscurantistes on nous fait
souvent nous prouve le procès vous savez
les vmc compte progrès vous est d offrir
en dise aujourd'hui ceux qui veulent
effet la vérité les choses mesurables
c'est nous ceux qui veulent empêcher
cela ce sont les promoteurs des ogm
ceux qui ont du business à faire dans ce
domaine là et donc là je dis bien il
faut peut-être inverser la charge de la
preuve
alors vous il ya des raisons de ne pas
faire confiance
aux industriels qui refusent
l'étiquetage est ce qu'on peut faire
confiance aux autorités européennes de
contrôle
celles qui sont chargés d'assurer cette
transparence et l'instant où ces
autorités et son passé moi l'expression
cul et chemise avec avec l'industrie
l'industrie agroalimentaire on a un
véritable problème les conflits
d'intérêts entre ceux qui font partie
des panels d'évaluation des produits au
sein de l'agencé européenne de sécurité
alimentaire et l'industrie sont légion
c'est la directrice même dudu de l'
agence qui a dû démissionner même de
conflit d'intérêts mais évidemment est
donc là la confiance a été ébranlée et
donc aujourd'hui je pense que la sagesse
je recommanderais que quelques états
membres commandite une réédition de
l'étude du professeur séralini pour
confirmer ou infirmer ces résultats de
manière à ce qu'on puisse avoir un point
de vue réellement indépendant à la fois
de l'industrie et d'une agence dont on
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui elle ne jouit
plus de la confiance des législateurs
ici dans cette maison
donc il faut revoir le système de
contrôle européen mais je crois en tout
cas qu'il faut mettre en place des
règles de
de gestion des conflits d'intérêts
extrêmement strictes de manière à éviter
que ceux qui sont dans les panels
d'évaluation n'est pour la moindre
raison partie liée avec l'industrie
c'est l'un ou l'autre vous devez choisir
ou bien vous êtes un évaluateur ou bien
vous êtes salarié de l'industrie mais
vous ne pouvez pas faire les deux on
sait que les lobbys sont très puissants
on les voit ici au parlement européen ce
que vous pensez que le rapport cette
question des ogm il y a aussi une
influence des lobbys c'est ça que mes
goûts
je suis dessus les choses ministre en
qui ne sont pas effrayés par des lobbys
c'est clair qu'il y à une activité de
lobbying intense qui se parlent qui se
passe ici au parlement européen
mais la question c'est les députés
sont-ils assez solide pour résister à
cela ces jeux tous à la question qu'on
doit se poser personnellement j'ai tous
les jours des banquiers dans dans mon
bureau
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils viennent me
mélanger disais que je vois le goal com
com com comme l'évangile est donc très
franchement moi je n'ai pas peur des
lobbyistes ce que je constate peut-être
sais que certains d'entre nous sont
peut-être plus réceptifs à son argument
surtout quand on leur dit faites
attention ne régule n'est pas parce que
ça risque de tuer l'économie européenne
c'est une sorte de lieu commun qu'on
entend à tous les sujets je pense que
les industriels ne sont peut-être pas
les mieux placés pour nous dire ce qu'il
faut faire pour ainsi assurer l'avenir
de notre économie
merci beaucoup philippe lambert on vous
laisse repartir dans l'hémicycle mais
l'émission continue on se rend cette
semaine en grèce la grèce ou la crise
sanitaire succède à la crise économique
manque de médecins hôpitaux débordés
regardez cet état des lieux réalisé par
betty lachguer avec georges et à
beaucourt
athènes aujourd'hui la capitale est
aussi connue pour ses vestiges que pour
son économie ruinée par la crise
les grecs s'enfonce de plus en plus dans
la pauvreté
au point de renoncer à se soigner c'est
le cas de génie voilà ça c'est mauvais
génie à 63 ans elle est retraitée depuis
deux ans mais l'état ne lui a toujours
rien versé sans pension
impossible pour elle de payer son
assurance maladie tout ce qui les
intéresse ce sont des taxes en plus de
son cholestérol et de son asthme
eugénie a contracté une grippe h1n1 il
ya un an et demi
depuis elle n'a pas vu un seul médecin
aujourd'hui c'est une tumeur au ventre
qui l'inquiète
on m'a donné un papier pour aller
enlever les tumeurs il y avait écrit
dessus qu'elle est sans ressources il
est urgent d'enlever la tumeur il m'a
envoyé balader c'était dans un hôpital
un ami lui conseille alors d'aller à la
polyclinique de médecins du monde pour
se faire soigner gratuitement tout va
beaucoup plus vite
elle obtient deux rendez vous en moins
d'une semaine
aujourd'hui elle s'y rend pour se faire
examiner ça fait mal ça ressemble à des
ganglions
pendant ce temps là le centre de soins
ne désemplit pas à l'origine seules des
migrants ou des demandeurs d'asile y
était reçue depuis trois ans
la cinquantaine de bénévoles a vu
affluer un nouveau public de grecs votre
colonne va bien pas de souci ces
documents viennent de l'hôpital moi je
voulais un avis neutre d'un médecin ici
il voit plus de gens qui viennent de
tous les coins du monde et surtout je
viens parce que j'ai conscience et si
les athéniens se détournent des hôpitaux
publics
c'est aussi parce qu'il faut payer 5
euros de droit d'entrée et apporter ses
propres médicaments alors qu'ici tout
est gratuit
j'espère que les choses vont s'arranger
s'améliorer là j'ai l'impression qu'on
est au fond du trou que ça peut pas être
pire
aujourd'hui près de 50% des patients
sont grecs face à cette augmentation les
ong a donc dû s'adapter
les bénévoles ont arrêté leurs missions
à l'étranger pour pouvoir s'occuper des
grecs les plus démunis
cela fait déjà deux trois ans qu'un
grand nombre de personnes une grosse
vague ne peut pas subvenir à des besoins
essentiels et cela est dû à une hausse
du taux de chômage en fait que de plus
en plus de personnes ne sont pas assurés
et ça c'est grave parce que ça touche
aussi leur enfant retour avec eugénie au
delà de la consultation médicale elle
est aussi venu chercher un peu de
réconfort une oreille attentive
avant moi je travaillais dans
l'entreprise de chocolat yo yo mais ce
sont mes chocolats préférées hamon à
l'époque j'étais une vraie dame voulait
toujours il ne faut pas abuser c'est pas
l'argent qui fait de vous une vraie dame
la fin de la consultation
eugénie attend maintenant son tour pour
récupérer ses médicaments
donc voila tu as compris comment ça se
passe ça c'est pour 5 millilitres donc
toi c'est cinq fois qu'il faut remplir
cette mission fait aujourd'hui partie du
quotidien delo ong
car faute d'approvisionnement les
pharmacies grecs n'ont tout simplement
plus de médicaments alors un médecin du
monde
la solidarité s'organise la plupart des
médicaments ce sont des dons de médecins
du monde
là c'est un médecin qui a changé la
prescription d'un patient et il n'a plus
besoin d'une boîte
donc il nous l'a rapporté les gens
récupèrent aussi les boîtes des amis ou
des proches
eugénie rentrer chez elle mais elle va
devoir revenir dans deux jours pour
passer des radiographies
je vais prendre un peu de ventoline ça
va pas trop finalement même lorsqu'elle
aura une pension et une assurance
maladie
eugénie ne compte pas retourner à
l'hôpital je veux avoir confiance en
allant dans un hôpital où on puisse
l'examiner de manière humaine on n'est
pas des animaux
on a travaillé pour cet état pourri on a
beaucoup donné et on nous considère
comme des déchets cas marcheurs ont
achoppé comme jenny 30% de la population
auraient déjà été exclus du système de
santé grec
et si l'état prévoit encore de nouvelles
coupes dans ce secteur la santé pourrait
bientôt devenir un privilège au lieu
d'un droit alors là donc pour ce
reportage à athènes nous avons été
rejoints par pierre vermeren bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de
médecins du monde ici en belgique donc
la même ong que celle que nous allons
devoir dans le reportage est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'il y a actuellement en
grèce une véritable crise sanitaire
je pense qu'on peut le dire dans le sens
où les budgets hospitaliers ont été
réduits de 40%
donc on ne sait pas continuer un système
de santé en tout cas au niveau
hospitalier avec de telles coupes
budgétaires donc mais je pense que les
l'impact et on le voit dans dans ce
reportage l'impact sur la population est
structurelle et donc on a des monsieur
madame tout le monde qui sont
directement impactés
parce que c'est ça la nouveauté en fait
avant c'était des personnes ont des
immigrés sans papiers etc
là ce sont des grecs maintenant on va
dire de la classe moyenne qui viennent
chez vous celui qu'on voit ça c'est
généralement le les systèmes de santé
mais les systèmes généraux de sécurité
sociale
cette tendance à exclure ceux qui se
trouvent à la marge dans la grande
précarité
ce qui vient de l'extérieur etc
aujourd'hui c'est le coeur même qui est
touchée alors c'est le coeur certes des
personnes qui sont les moins bien nantis
donc des personnes qui ont une équipe
des travailleurs sans emploi des
personnes âgées des pensionnés et puis
progressivement
si les coupes continuent et sa touche de
plus en plus la classe la classe moyenne
ce qui constitue un problème général que
ce soit sur fait classe moyenne ou sur
les personnes de précariser donc en
grèce oui on peut parler de crise
sanitaire en tout cas au niveau
hospitalier au niveau d'un médecine
qu'il ya un deuxième problème c'est
celui de la confiance on ne voit très
bien dans le reportage je sais que le
système sanitaire pose alors un problème
d'accès et les personnes perdent
confiance dans ce système et ça c'est
quelque chose qui touche tout le monde
et auquel il faut être extrêmement
attentif parce que des organisations
comme médecins du monde non pas du tout
vocation à remplacer le système c'est
simplement ddd révélateur de problèmes
et donc il faut vraiment veiller à ce
que les systèmes santé garde la
confiance de la population pari de la
confiance dans le système de santé
est-ce que ce qui est en train de se
passer actuellement en grèce c'est né de
la crise économique et sociale
exclusivement où ça vient aussi parce
que déjà avant cette crise il y avait un
problème on sait qu' il ya un problème
de corruption en grèce est ce que cette
ce problème et j'arrive dire
conjoncturelle ou est-ce qu'il est
structurel le problème que nous
rencontrons dans ce reportage est
extrêmement lié à la crise économique et
financière de la grèce
et comme on dit représenter le système
grec comme un autre système comme étant
un système parfait et qui a basculé dans
des grandes difficultés qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui ce serait une erreur
évidemment mais je pense que notre
objectif n'est pas de refaire l'histoire
du système de santé publique grecque
par contre ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui est
clairement conjoncturel est clairement
lié à des coupes budgétaires très
significatif très dur sur le système de
santé l'un des médecins disaient on est
au fond du trou
ça peut pas être pire est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça ou est-ce que vous
pensez que malheureusement ça peut
encore être pire et je vais j'espère
qu'il a raison évidemment donc par
contre je ne crois pas à la mécanique du
fond qui fait que ont rebondi on peut
toujours descendre plus loin je pense
qu'effectivement si on continue à avoir
un système qui est attaquée avec des
coupes budgétaires comme celle-là
immanquablement ce sont les généralistes
qui ne pourront plus donner de soi dans
une couverture universelle et le
problème de la santé un peu comme le
logement mais certainement dans la santé
c'est plus clair cette une couverture
universelle qui est absolument
nécessaire parce que dès qu'on commence
à exclure des populations dès qu'on
commence à demander un système
assurantiel où les gens on doit fait la
démarche de se couvrir au bout du compte
toutes les politiques de santé publique
ne sont plus réalisable parce que des
gens sont dedans et des gens sont en
dehors
est ce qu'il y à un phénomène un peu
général on vient de voir l'exemple grec
mais est ce que dans toute cette europe
qui est profondément touchée sur le plan
social par la crise est-ce que les
aspects sanitaires sont importants
ailleurs vous voyez j'imagine vous avez
des des dispensaires un petit peu
partout en europe en espagne au portugal
par exemple tout à fait donc on voit et
au portugal en espagne en grèce en
france en belgique en hollande en
angleterre dans les dispensaires que
nous avons ouvert on voit le même type 2
de tendance est à dire on commence à
toucher au coeur des populations et plus
à tous ceux qui étaient en périphérie
qui n'avait déjà pas accès au système
aujourd'hui c'est les gens qui avaient
accès au système qui n'ont plus accès à
ce système notion même par exemple en
france où ou en belgique
mais en france on va voir par exemple
une augmentation significative et en
belgique également du nombre de
personnes mal logées dans le nombre de
personnes sans abri ou simplement mal
logés et donc on va voir que pendant des
périodes hivernales des maladies vont se
créer 6 et dans une population qui
jusqu'ici était quand même relativement
bien prise en charge parce que les
systèmes de santé hospitaliers donc
deuxième niveau ou de premier niveau des
généralistes avaient la possibilité
avait les marges pour les prendre en
charge et aujourd'hui elles ont à
l'image et donc et donc ces personnes se
retrouvent avec un suivi médical qui est
largement fragilisée oui est ce que vous
diriez peut-être pour conclure que
médecins du monde et d'autres ong sont
en train malgré elle de remplacer les
états qui sont défaillants non vraiment
ce n'était pas du tout l'objectif de
médecins du monde de remplacer objectif
vous faites ce n'est pas ce qu'on fait
ce que notre de ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui est de montrer à travers des
exemples extrêmement concret mais sur
des tranches de population parce que
nous ne savons pas où offrir une
couverture universelle c'est de montrer
les les implications des choix qui sont
faits nous ne sommes nous ne saurons
nous ne pouvons pas en normes ayant
trois quatre vingt trente quarante
centres remplacer les milliers de
centres de santé qui font un travail
extraordinaire au quotidien merci
beaucoup
pierre vermeren d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans europe hebdo c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires